okay we could have all guessed this but
it's still shocking to see a brand new
media Research Center study revealing
that out of 115 election stories from
ABC NBC CBS
87 treated Republicans negatively
despite Democrats being the party in
power of course now they also looked at
how individual candidates fared well my
next guest is the only one who received
already ready ready for this zero
positive stories according to the study
a hundred percent of the coverage about
Arizona gubernatorial candidate
carry a lake from the big three networks
was negative now despite that lake is
still up by nearly three in the most
recent RCP average and she joins me now
now Carrie first of all it's great to
see you tonight okay this is
hysterically funny in one way another
way it's very depressing but how are you
coping with this news that the coverage
has been 100 percent negative do you
need like a a fruit basket or do you
need any kind of like a security blanket
to get yourself through this difficult
time I need a safe space and an
emotional you know support animal to get
through it I'm going to wear it as a
badge of honor truly that the fake news
media sees this movement of Mama bears
out here in Arizona as such a threat to
their agenda that they're running a
hundred percent negative stories on me
but the amazing thing is is just
revealing Laura that they've lost their
power if they're putting a hundred
percent negative stories on me and the
last poll I saw yesterday showed us up
11. I don't think it's working anymore
the people are awake to the garbage that
they're peddling well your opponent
um made a recent comment that I thought
I'd share watch
we're talking about the economy to
voters every single day it's one of the
top concerns and we're talking about the
plans that we have to actually address
uh inflation Kerry Lake doesn't have an
economic plan that does anything except
make inflation worse
uh so I must have missed all those Town
Halls on the economy that Katie Hobbs
did and what is she talking about
well first of all her tax plan which by
the way the fake news covered as if it
was the greatest thing ever is about
taking and removing the tax off of
diapers and feminine hygiene products
and look I that's great but we got to go
better and farther than that okay and my
tax plan my inflation relief for the
hard-working people of Arizona is to get
rid of our grocery tax and the tax we
pay on rent on renting a department or a
home those are two areas that will help
the bottom line for hard-working
arizonans and people who are struggling
right now and that'll put a half a
billion dollars immediately back into
the pockets of Arizona Citizens We're
going to go even further by cutting
taxes every year including sales tax
property tax we'll try to trim down the
income tax as well she doesn't have a
plan and her plan is basically whatever
Joe Biden is doing and it's Joe Biden
and his terrible economic policies that
have gotten us into this hyperinflation
and the mess we're in right now it's
going to take some strong Republicans to
get us out well they keep doing that
doing the same thing over and over again
you know another speech about democracy
being threatened by the Republicans uh
then you had my orcas uh out of course
DHS Chief talking about the border and
again not connecting on the issue I want
to play this sound bite and get your
reaction from my orcas
there are a number of
forces that are feeling a violent
extremism
ideologies of hate
false narratives
anti-government sentiment personal
grievances the divisiveness in this
country is uh of great concern
uh Carrie clearly there's an attempt to
criminalize the political opposition
here they're not talking about
individual acts of violence which we all
condemn and we all uh absolutely think
are reprehensible whoever care is
carrying them out this is really an
effort to I think ostracize demonize and
ultimately cancel the entire
conservative perspective including yours
I mean part of what he's talking about
Biden's talking about is this election
denier negativity all of that your
reaction tonight they're trying to keep
us from speaking out as people are
waking up to the lies they're trying to
get us uh to be quiet and not speak out
and I distinctly remember the summer of
2020 there was a lot of violence on the
streets and the left wasn't speaking out
against the churches burning in
Washington D.C being burnt and rioted
and Portland being riding and burning
going on of our buildings and all of the
big cities blue cities uh liberal cities
I don't remember them speaking out
against that violence and I'm I'm
absolutely opposed to violence of any
kind I wish mayorcas would actually do
his job and work to stop the flow of
illegals coming across our border we
don't know who these people are we know
many of them have records and it's
hurting our country I really wish he'd
get on that instead of trying to stoke
political
agitation across this country and make
things worse and more divided yeah the
the crowd of Venezuelans that rushed the
Border uh yesterday was horrific border
patrol agents lives are being put in
Jeopardy and I think this is also
playing into the shift among Women
Voters especially Suburban Women Voters
carry uh the Wall Street Journal poll
that came out said that the GOP now has
seen a shift among white Suburban women
that group shifted 26 percentage points
away from the Democrats since the
journal's August poll now favors the GOP
again White Suburban women by 15
percentage points now to what do you
attribute that
oh I saw it just last night you know we
hold big events every day we're holding
between six and ten meetings and events
each day last night we had a wonderful
rally it was packed hundreds of people
and so many of them Laura were moms I
call them my mama bears and at the end
when I went and talked to him went into
the crowd they were we were taking
pictures and just talking about how
worried we are about our children in the
future and that's what it's about moms
want Safe Streets they want to fully
fund our Police Department so that they
know that crime is kept low and when
they call 9-1-1 they can get help they
want to make sure the border is secure
because they don't want fentanyl pouring
across getting into the hands of young
people and they want educational
opportunities where our kids in high
school can get trade skill training
vocational training or career
certification in high school so they're
ready for the real jobs that are out
there these are all parts of my platform
I think that's why they're with us and
they also know that they want someone
who's going to protect their kids from
these new forced shots that the CDC is
recommending in order for our children
to be able to go to school I spoke out
immediately and said we'll never make
our kids guinea pigs we will never Force
those shots on our children my opponent
her answer when asked if she would force
our kids to get those experimental shots
her answer was ah uh I don't know I
haven't thought about it I mean this is
why they're voting for us in record
numbers at Freedom safety Common Sense
uh Carey you're surprising a lot of
people out there and I can't wait to see
what plays out on Tuesday night we're
going to be watching if we don't talk to
you beforehand best of luck on the trail
up until Tuesday we hope you talk talk
to you soon after that hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else